- Talk about the best
practices on Snapchat.
- He's clearly thinking about
marketing from a direct response
click attribution
tactical standpoint.
That's like saying I don't get
what being on TV all the time
does for my business.
'Cause nobody's clicking
from their TV and buying
Kelly Rippa's book.
- [Woman] Mhmmm.
- So what he is is he's base,
you tell your man that he's
basic thinking.
He's thinking one chess move.
It's called branding.
There's two separate things.
One's called branding,
one's called sales.
- [Woman] Right.
- He's talking sales.
That's one step, right?
You go on Google you
buy an ad, you click it,
you sell, that's a sale.
But branding is different.
What does Taylor Swift get out
of like surprising a fan and
bringing them on stage?
She didn't get a transaction.
Nobody touched the
screen and bought her album.
She built brand.
- [Woman] Yep.
- It made you
think something, like,
so they're thinking too basic.
Snapchat, I have 30,000 people
watching every one of my
Snapchat stories.
- [Woman] Right.
- Right, I Snap me
walking into here.
What did, they didn't click
it and bought my book but I'm
painting a narrative of my life.
They're becoming interested and
then when I ask for it somewhere
else tactically so
I'm playing chess and
I think your
man's playing checkers.